[Music]
being a beautiful you look gorgeous as
always
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you look gorgeous
thank you thanks for being here I
haven't having like an allergy attack
right now so I'm kind of it might be me
that might be a lot of women start
sneezing around me
hello and I where is it yeah it's I just
rub myself with corn husks right out of
a shower so much stuff but first of all
I just saw you the other night speak at
the Democratic National Convention good
for you that must have been a real
thrill yeah that's a massive
responsibility huge and I was listen to
your speech and you said something that
I can't my tent right away you were
talking about how you used to work as an
auto mechanic yeah for a brief period of
time yeah I have to tell you I found
that throwing oil I used change what
well you know what I started as a
delivery girl like didn't deliver parts
so people would order like light bulbs
so I could go deliver so there'd be men
that would see you and then they would
just start ordering stuff they didn't
need I need whatever you have I need one
of those immediately yeah so I'm just
picturing you working on a car I just
think that's this yeah it's very sexy
did you wear the overalls and you know
no no no no I just
Warp jeans I was in college so it was
like one of my ten jobs right yeah but
my point was that I'm living the
American dream and so it was exciting to
talk to to have that platform and talk
to America and to build an America where
that dream is still possible for
everybody and I think Obama's gonna do
that yeah well very good and I won't ask
us about the oh okay good please
what happened down there
never get politics what they
[Applause]
you're talking about political issues
people and you're like what's going on
over here what okay okay can help them
right here to help the doctors ready to
operate I'm such an idiot
my Korean wife is about to leave me
thrilled she lives
you're all so this is exciting you're
you're hosting co-hosting the Alma
Awards yeah this is American Latin Media
Awards okay and and you're you've
already announced that there should be a
lot of costume changes for you as yeah I
do it's like it's a gay NASCAR it's like
I love gayness yeah it's literally the
changes are like two three minutes and I
change like 10 times within the show and
so I just stand there and dresses
earrings are flying and makeup and hair
and so you go into an area you do your
bit on television then you go to an area
box yeah like a curtain yeah curtain
doff and then I I'm just there
I stand there and then it's just and all
these people yes like ten people are
doing there I just one get that job I'm
just now it's t me buds the people that
create this again I'm always happy to
help
it's funny because people I don't know
how many people are aware of the concept
of seat fillers it's a job but it award
shows there are seat fillers yeah so is
that people that dress up nicely and if
celebrities when you get a good camera
shot of the audience there aren't any
empty chairs when like Tom Cruise goes
to the bathroom really or something
there's a lot now and I was a seat
filler at the Alma Awards 10 years ago I
used to be a seat though isn't that
question that you were a seat filler and
now you're hosting the event and I
executive produce it yeah that is
fantastic and I
but my dad didn't really know about seat
fillers so he came to the Ole Miss a
couple years ago when I was hosting and
he went to the bathroom and he came back
and he saw somebody was in a seat so he
left he was like he went away he went
back to the bar and the whole show he
stood in the back because he's like I
guess somebody somebody didn't know that
guess when you go up to those people
they they switch back out with you if
it's really yours you have to go that's
my seat I was a seat filler when I first
got in the business music award shows a
good show you could you can make a
little money so I would show and what I
always knows I don't you do this but if
you're a seat filler you come to the
rehearsals sometimes and if they
announce you as the winner you're
supposed to go up yeah you can give a
speech to sort of help the cameramen
practice how long you're up there and
some of the people would go on and on
and on as if they had really won the
award yeah I saw like an old okay maybe
me
I actually was Tina Turner I was it was
1989 and I was you know like 21 years
old I was playing Tina Turner they said
the winner is Tina Turner and for
practice I got up and I gave a 40-minute
talk